Have you heard about using low-dose neltrexone for cancer?
Yeah, yep. So you can do that too.
That's not something that we can prescribe because that's a medication.
It is, most of the research on low-dose neltrexone, we've talked about this
I'd like to be more. It's really an
immune regulator. So it is more commonly used for severe auto-immune conditions
but it can be used with cancer especially if a person's immune system is really
really hindered. That's where you get back to. This would be an option for that person
back here where try to get your lymphocytes up. That would, if you can't get your lymphocytes up
maybe because this person is doing chemo or something like that, that would low-dose neltrexone
would be something that if I was in that situation that I would consider.
There's really really no side effects that I know with low-dose neltrexone.
Typically it's given at a little bit higher dose than 0.5. Typically you start out at one point
five milligrams and for a few weeks then you move to three and then you move to four point five
milligrams. That's the typical dosage progression of LDN but you can talk to a practitioner that would
order that for you. Any compounded local lab one can get that for you.
Artemisinin is also very good for cancers or in a big fan of Artemisinin.
That's one of the things we always test for.